how's it goin everybody we have even
more leaks for Avengers 4 as some of you
may recall about a month ago the Russo
brothers posted this picture on social
media the photo was captioned look hard
and it sent the internet into a frenzy
many people believe that the title for
Avengers 4 could possibly be in the
picture but I think the general belief
now is that he actually revealed the
proton cannon one fan noticed that a
machine that is in this photo is
actually in a scene in Avengers infinity
war as well and when you compare the two
there's zero doubt that this is the same
machine it's definitely this same
machine and then fans started to notice
that this looks an awful lot like war
machine and Iron Man's proton cannon
some people doubted this theory but
today the theory gets a lot more
evidence thanks to a leaked set photo of
the avengers headquarters provided to us
by the geek power we get a closer look
at this machine it's without a doubt the
same machine that is in the Russo
brothers photo and it's without a doubt
the same machine that is in the scene
from Avengers infinity war this looks
just like Iron Man and war machines
proton cannon for the most part they
look exactly the same the shape the
color and the size are exactly the same
as Iron Man and war machines proton
cannon and it makes sense that they
would introduce the proton cannon in
Avengers 4 they're going to need
everything they can get to defeat Thanos
in Avengers 4 and this mysterious new
villain that we're supposed to get so it
looks like Iron Man and war machine are
literally going to be pulling out the
big guns
boom you looking for this
it seems to me like this photo confirms
that the proton cannon will be in
Avengers 4 but let me know what you all
think let me know if you think it's the
proton cannon or if it could be
something else also my giveaway still
continues if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win a copy of infinity
war or ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber like the video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]